i'm going to talk about the seven
unexpected amazing benefits of the trace
mineral zinc now i would say out of all
the health topics
making this minor tweak in your diet
will probably result in one of the major
improvements
in your health because zinc is involved
in more enzyme systems
than
all of the other trace minerals combined
and
over 2 billion people are deficient in
zinc and one of the big problems with
zinc is that there's no functional
storage of zinc in your body so as soon
as you stop getting zinc from the diet
you're going to be deficient and you
might think that you can just determine
a zinc deficiency by a blood test
but most of the zinc is not in the blood
it's in the cells
and so we're going to talk about that
so let's dive into the first point the
most concentrated amount of zinc is
located in the prostate gland okay
because it's involvement with
sperm and testosterone
etc
and so zinc helps someone maintain their
testosterone levels and if they're
deficient they're definitely going to
experience problems with low
testosterone low libido and even
something called hypogonadism
in which the testicle actually atrophies
so many people don't realize the
importance of getting enough zinc to
maintain the testosterone levels all
right number two
and this one is a really really
interesting one
zinc has a major role in
maintaining your insulin levels okay as
well as the insulin binding to your
liver cells
so the second most concentrated area
for zinc in your body
is in the pancreas
specifically the cells that produce
insulin in the pancreas they're called
the beta cells
and so when we're dealing with diabetes
for example zinc becomes very very
important
now before you get diabetes you get
pre-diabetes before you get pre-diabetes
you have insulin resistance pretty much
all diabetics have insulin resistance in
fact the majority of the population on
planet earth has insulin resistance i've
talked extensively about this topic but
the importance of zinc
in avoiding or preventing in some
resistance is uh is not really well
known
so
you may already know that if someone has
insulin resistance you're very
susceptible to getting a fatty liver
cirrhosis of the liver
um increase your risk of getting a
stroke
heart attack
obesity
high blood pressure but if you don't
have enough zinc
your beta cells the cells that make
insulin become fatigued now just think
about this what determines someone going
into a pre-diabetic and then a diabetic
situation now when someone has diabetes
insulin is no longer working or it's
becoming less and less in the body and
then the blood sugars start to go out of
control they start increasing because
insulin kind of keeps the blood sugar in
check
so
when someone eats a lot of sugar
normally you have insulin that comes in
there and it keeps the sugar down so
your blood sugars don't build up and
they can be maintained you can do that
for a period of time but eventually over
the years maybe i don't know 10 15 20
years
it's that beta cell starts to become
fatigue well what i believe that's
happening deep in the cells is that
somehow a person loses the amount of
zinc
that's in that pancreas
then
the beta cell starts burning out that's
when you start having
diabetes and more complications
because zinc is a very powerful
antioxidant and
the fact that
someone's consuming a lot of
carbohydrates and the insulin is high
that right there will deplete your zinc
even more so it's kind of like is it the
chicken of the egg well
a zinc deficiency can set you up for
weakness with having a problem with the
beta cell but then the diet of consuming
all those carbs are going to deplete you
in zinc so then the fact that the person
now has diabetes creates more of a zinc
deficiency so what you need to know is
that zinc is really really really
important
in
helping someone overcome pre-diabetes
and diabetes so zinc will help lower
your blood sugars and make insulin more
sensitive all right number three this is
also very interesting
the third most concentrated tissue
with zinc in your body is your muscles
and so zinc is needed for muscle repair
and regeneration but
even if someone is deficient in zinc
apparently the muscles can still
function fine
except one muscle and that muscle is the
soleus muscle now what is the soleus
muscle that is the muscle in your calf
just underneath
another calf muscle called the
gastrocnemius muscle so the soleus is a
deeper calf muscle that attaches to your
achilles tendon it can withstand a
tremendous amount of load
and out of all the muscles in the body
the soleus has the highest concentration
of zinc and so the soleus is very very
important in
endurance so a long distance runner
needs a very healthy soleus someone that
is a basketball player that uses
explosive movements needs a very healthy
sonya's muscle and when you're deficient
in zinc
the soleus can actually
atrophy it can have a dysfunction in
contraction and relaxation
making you more susceptible to getting
an injury with the knee as well as the
calf
as well as the achilles tendon if you're
trying to build a calf muscle and you
don't have enough zinc you may find that
you never develop your calf muscles now
as a side note there's four times more
zinc in red meat than white meat now a
lot of people that are working out
consume
like chicken breast
broccoli
rice
grains right and what they don't know is
because they're not consuming enough red
meat
they're probably not going to get as
much zinc not to mention when you
consume grains that have this
chemical called phytic acid which is a
naturally occurring chemical that locks
up zinc and other minerals
that could be one reason why they're
deficient in fact a good portion of the
population on planet earth is deficient
in zinc because they consume
cereals which are grains
which block the absorption of zinc so
zinc is very important to the soleus
muscle
in protecting the knee and the ankle and
your ability to perform sports number
four
your thymus gland the main gland that is
involved in your immune system it's
right on top of the heart it's different
than the thyroid it's called the thymus
okay and if you're deficient in zinc
one big problem you may experience is
find this atrophy okay and then what can
result from that is low t cells and low
antibodies and think about your immune
system if you have low antibodies and
low t cells you can't fight as long so
if someone is you can't fight it can't
fight infections so it happens the
duration of infections are a lot longer
if you are zinc deficient now number
five you may know if you're deficient in
vitamin a you might have problems seeing
at night
but zinc is just as important as vitamin
a in making the active form of vitamin a
activated okay so if you're deficient in
zinc
yet you're still consuming enough
vitamin a you might still have a problem
seeing in the dark so in other words
vitamin a needs zinc to work all right
number six your skin needs zinc without
enough zinc you're going to notice
you'll get dry
flaky
skin your skin will become roughened it
won't be nice and smooth and number
seven
intestinal inflammation
a lot of remedies for either
an ulcer in your small intestine or your
stomach become greatly improved with
zinc if you're deficient in zinc your
risk for getting inflammatory conditions
goes way up and then when you have
inflammation in your intestine
that can block your ability to absorb
zinc
so this is why so many people with gut
issues have skin issues because of this
lack of absorption of zinc now how do we
become deficient in zinc there are
several key things i'm just going to run
through them uh birth control pills can
cause a zinc deficiency uh consuming a
lot of refined carbs or sugar create a
deficiency of zinc
phytic acid in grains will block zinc
stress
cortisol and even the medication called
prednisone which is a synthetic version
of cortisol can deplete your zinc having
low hydrochloric acid can prevent your
ability to absorb zinc
which is very common if you're over the
age of 45 and alcohol can create a zinc
deficiency now if you want a really high
quality
zinc product that has all the trace
minerals
i put a link down below in the
description and the next best video for
you to watch would be how to test
yourself
to determine if you have a zinc
deficiency i put that video up right
here to check it out
you